I noticed more in the earlier variations
we are doing in the later ones a lot of
times I always my foot land my foot has
not yet or ever
particularly the very first one did less
so on the second one myself later on
especially on the first one and then
later that I was just not finding the
friend like I wasn't getting close at
all like I jumped from being oddly close
to being very distant so you're having
inconsistency in the timing and
distancing my okay so you know it's true
up to a point there's a time and
distance and everything okay it is true
look took like there's rhythm and
everything but ultimately time and space
rhythm range these are dichotomous
and they come from a antagonistic
understanding of you and you kid
no matter what okay so what I'm about to
say you just got it's beginner level
stuff okay what was happening in the
first rep is nobody was using the
controlling attendant to see and so
bouquet was doing whatever retail is
doing so as alerting her though your
kami is as prescribed as your Nagato
that means your mind is controlled as
well if they have that at any their or
not you should not be closing the gap on
them do you understand
day after do you still have your skill
set to learn
you don't take Academy for your
classmates you take your Kimmie for your
teacher that's that's the skill the one
who can damage you the most well it
should be the teacher right you want to
be able to receive that technique so
that you feel that
so that yours continues to improve so
when I was just a deci oh yeah
most people are brain farting right
they're not how I judge my proficiency
they might not even be there next week
so I don't go and start closing the gap
on the okay I'm the nagas I'm sorry
because if I did that on my teacher only
bad things happen to me because it
presents an opening do you see dispense
to the next two counters why don't I
learn instead what this time-space
idealized time-space is in the art
because it is weapon based and why waste
fifty percent of my time time to learn
it as naga is learning the weapon based
fighting distance who kids learning the
same thing so you don't want to crowd
naga it's showing up unawareness of all
that's going to happen here instead
learn kinesthetically i'm always about
this far I'm always about this
always about this fun let the teacher
correct the noggin
dude you don't have the attendant it
didn't
again remember hee haw Massa Duke Emmy
is as prescribed and as idealized as the
noggin it's not a free-for-all that even
if this last technique I was telling I
made the distinction that good again
will put their head in the middle
because that's the prescribed energy
frame for that technique why is that the
good again because there's an
unconsciousness to the battery kid who's
still doing the first technique why
because that one was not scared why
because that one I kind of got to throw
myself with some of the nagas here but
this last one I don't get a choice I
gotta go right why why did you get to
know yourself the first time because
there was no fulcrum in here in the in
the noggin the nog it was just
accelerating you that's you you you tend
to go well it's easier to roll than to
run out of things you could have run out
of every one of those things but once
they got the full from your hip in there
now your
and sometimes you were with those Nagas
and you learned that that's when you
have to smile on your back or on your
tailbone or you learned the other lesson
where they're not doing momentum Roli
and now you can't throw them because you
don't have the fall from you here so you
don't have the other component of the
topsy-turvy effect you see they're not
being jerks the running momentum against
Romania jerks they're the ones really
need their proper tips unless you put
that hip in there you make them want to
pull out that's telling you it's telling
you do you understand that's why they're
pulling out because you're throwing
so even now I'm who care and my noggin
doesn't have the attend me and they
don't have the fall coming hips I'm not
gonna throw myself what I tend to do is
we don't going to feel my way Davis not
going to work and in the class like he
won't Wazza right
I kind of I'm not resisting their
technique
I'm not going young against them I feel
all the young spots right I'm not
shutting them down we play a kind of
games with the beginner so okay you
don't have it here's where you stopped
me and then I kind of get myself into
position from them because that's the
prescribed to kami
you see that they didn't get me there
I'll get myself didn't they can do do
you understand that that works because
they get to see more of the technique
than if you just shut them down where
you just pull out you get it it comes
with stages though so they're not
actually doing it but they're getting a
little piece I know a little piece and a
little piece do you see and they need
the exposure for it but understand the
larger amount
the Lukas you are pulling out are
telling you something and when you pull
out is telling you something about you
and when the my is wrong is telling you
something you should go home and go man
why did that
why did I keep stepping on that way
Steve why couldn't I saw that person
what were the corrections my teacher
kept saying over and over again to do
this is this conscientious training
improvement is now possible if you plug
in the exposure duration rates necessary
for treatment but to go home and like
duh and then you get sucked back into
the material world
but is so bad a life to go home and
think about right conflict resolution at
a physical level mmm that or binge watch
Netflix
so trying to remember Kimmy's got a role
Lucas got a role to do and as a role
like all other rules we'd probably have
to go back five ten other levels to make
sure that's in place
so we got a good slow right to give you
time to see yourself
but you have to understand man they went
slow for me
because I can't get
should be able to tell when people
aren't lying seems evil always makes him
seem like world Devo that seems to only
certain people like I you know he didn't
realize how much mercy was given to you
because if you did take more
responsibility how far off the mark you
are
it's always like that's that's who we
are that's what we do but if you go home
and think about it when you review the
videos
I think most of you remember that story
we always saw my teachers the out of
alarm slow because everyone was so
in terms of I can't even see
what you're showing me sound familiar
and then what time he went his speed and
though I was sitting in the back and the
mat is filled with instructors so like
if he were in the rear of the movie
theater you get it you see in the back
of everyone's head he was not near us he
was far from there's lots of room 400
practice but he went at his speed and I
watched every head go do do this it is
televi know or knew how slow he was go
how do we have his time work for us like
that because our egoism
it's why I'm pointing out to you please
look if that speed is generating that
much fear and causing that much physical
disengagement I gotta get to work do you
do understand it's not it's not I don't
know what to say the foots not even on
the gas
you're just idle forward I got work to
do I can't be that afraid for that
disengaging because I can't see the art
at that level and at that pace it will
always be false we already talked about
the art does use forums and levers but
it's the its focal Amin gravity against
inertia right or friction against
momentum if we're going this slow how
sharp a fall term is that and how long a
letter is that because what's the amount
of inertia moment
on their right how much friction I'm not
seeing the heart it looks like all I
gotta do is let go it looks like all I
have to do is move all I got to do is
decide not to go with it do you sing for
you because you're seen in his total
stay
and the ego things or allows you to
think that you're seeing true the ego
won't let you go my eyes or what's the
let me change my eyes
that's what we trying to do when I say
let's train conscientiously kind of
change your eyes eyes in the way
they're stopping me from learning from
progressing this is why I say look at
the results because because these are
eyes will go I go all these
days I train all these hours I try
really hard
what is your result are you progressing
are you improving or are you plateau B
are you not improving it's harder for
eyes to see that or to deny it
do you understand
did you just take lifting right and you
lifted the same weight you're not
improving or you get knows her and your
amounts going down yeah you're getting
worse it's hard to deny that you just
have to look last week I had this on and
this week I have that alarm and that now
the neck oh man
it's kind of a hardy because I can't
really get IT and Aikido at the level of
being when I become so cold oriented but
don't kid yourself it's not the same
problem
this is self-analysis
if you look at the Geeta you know he's
not that bull already he's not the
little rainy because it's not attached
to the fruits but the entire thing is
about self analysis dude look at
yourself you're thinking is all jacked
up how do you know because look at you
look at you result right now it's effed
up you can't go in and you can't go out
- don't confuse these two kinds of
concern with the results
in a way and it's very unpopular now but
in a way you must not be as
compassionate with yourself as you are
with others
if that perspective is destroying you
it's gonna be really hard because you're
gonna have to be very soft and ginger
with gingerly with when you treat
yourself right and that falls right into
the homeostatic energy that prevents
transformation
you understand what I'm saying I find
there are times when I kind of go like
hey do you just accept where your app
but you know what when I look at that
there is so much huge effort when I
finally get to that comment by
comparatively the amount of energy and
work and hours and resources spent
beforehand if you saw two people who
were practicing self compassion you
wouldn't see that level of work on death
and as I watch and have trained people
over the generations I'm telling you
that people are way more fragile now
they cannot take
the trials are discipline okay you got
to work on that guess how you do it
Oh weird stress adaptation model I'm
gonna do it I'm gonna get on my ass
whoops I'm starting to break I'm gonna
ease up
I'm back I'm gonna get on my ass again
I won't broke a little lesson a little
later you get it but to think that you
can't achieve the results you want
I'm never pushing yourself always being
easy on yourself stay comfortable not be
concerned with your results or your lack
thereof that's really not going to
happen ever you're doing yourself and it
won't change no matter how bad it hurts
how fragile you might be it will not
change
- through the generations the ascetics
path has often been described as victory
over the self victory not deferring to
and even when you go to the kita look
who it is
it's a warrior
and look where he's at in a battle in a
war the seed of human religions picked a
warrior and a war
to describe the way
there's gotta be a reason they could
have picked anything
taking